without the moon the Earth would start
to rotate faster and faster we'd have
shorter days
and stronger winds
birds and insects would have a tough
time surviving the harsh winds
not only that ocean tides would start to
die down into tiny little waves
the moon's gravity helps create tides on
Earth bummed out that you can't rip some
gnarly waves anymore
both dude there'll be a much bigger
problem it would wipe out all of the sea
creatures that rely on the tides and
ocean currents for survival our whole
world would be literally flipped upside
down
the Earth would burn up our days would
be shorter and the moon wouldn't be
there to light up the night sky
[Music]